>> From the Congress
in Washington DC.
>> Please join me in welcoming
the author of "Girls Who Code;
Learn to Code and Change the
World" Reshma Saujani [applause].
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: Thank
you so much [applause].
I'm a little short, so I've
got to make this smaller.
How are you guys?
Good. Yeah, you feeling good?
All right, I'm going to tell
you a little bit about my story
and about why I spend my
life teaching girls how
to computer program.
So, that's me.
I am a weird person to
have started Girls Who Code
because I didn't know how to code,
until I started the organization.
I was terrified of math
and science growing up.
My parents came here as
refugees from Uganda.
And when we came to this country,
every nighty father would sit
at the dinner table and
he'd ask me what's 2 plus 2.
And I would immediately say five.
You know, those dinner conversations
made me really nervous.
Because, the answer didn't
come to me immediately.
And it made me feel like I
wasn't good at math or science.
I knew as a little girl, what
I wanted to do when I grow up.
Because my parents came here as
refugees, I love this country.
And my father would also, in
addition to those math questions,
every night he would read to me.
And he would read to
me about Dr. King,
and Mahatma Gandhi,
and Eleanor Roosevelt.
And I knew at a young age that
I wanted to change the world.
I woke up at age 33,
which is a long time
from where you guys
are at right now.
And I wasn't happy with what
I was doing professionally.
It was 2008, and I was watching
my mentor Hillary Clinton give her
first concession speech.
And she had this line
where she said, you know,
just because I failed doesn't
mean you shouldn't try too.
And I literally felt like
she was speaking to me.
So, at age 33, I decided to
run for United States Congress,
against someone who had been
there for a really long time.
I probably had like less
than a 1% chance of winning.
I had a thousand-page policy book.
I remember, the only thing
my friends and I knew how
to do was build a website,
and we built one.
And we raised like $50,000 from
Indian aunties that were just
so happy an Indian girl
was running for office.
But it was the best
10 months of my life.
And on election day, in my victory
party that never ended up happening,
I was holding my father's hand,
watching the returns come in.
And that little ticker was not
moving past 19% of the vote.
I had lost.
I was broke.
I was humiliated and I
had no contingency plan.
But as I went to bed that night
the faces that I kept seeing over,
and over, and over again
were actually the ones
that I had never met.
Because when you run for office, you
end up going into a lot of schools.
And I'd go into computer science
classes and robotics classes
and I'd see a lot of boys.
But I didn't see any girls.
And I kept asking myself,
where are the girls?
And this question of where are
the girls started as a question
and then I became really
obsessed with it.
Because I knew that young
women made up the majority
of college graduates, the
majority of our labor force.
But we weren't in this
industry called technology
that was literally
shaping everything
about the way we live and work.
My father, when I was growing up,
my father would always say to me,
Reshma you have three choices,
you can be a doctor, a
lawyer or an engineer.
Because he wanted me
to have a career
where I could buy a house, you know.
Maybe get a dog, have a
family, be economically secure.
And the thing is, we don't have this
conversation with our young folks,
especially our young women.
You know there's 500,000
open jobs right now
in computing and technology.
Last year, we graduated 40,000
computer science graduates.
China, for example,
graduated 350,000 graduates.
And these jobs aren't just in
New York City, where I'm from,
or Silicon Valley, which
I know you hear about.
They are everywhere.
Ninety-one percent of
these open jobs are outside
of our traditional tech ecosystem.
The problem is, is that we're
not graduating enough people.
And people always ask me well,
what's the solution to that.
And I think it's women power.
You know, I told you as many of
you know, women are the majority
in college, where they're
also, today they are 45%
of America's breadwinners.
And the thing is, is that
when it comes to technology,
we've had this tremendous
decline of women in technology.
In the 1980s, if you walked
into any gaming camp in America,
it would have been
half boys, half girls.
Today you walk into any computer
science classroom in America
and less than 1 out
of 5 will be girls.
For the girls in the room right now,
how many of you are taking
a computer science class,
raise your hand.
And how many of you are one of
the few girls in your classroom?
Keep your hand up.
Yeah. And the thing is, is you guys
are lucky because studies will show
that if you are a young
girl like you
and you haven't taken computer
science in high school,
you're unlikely to
take it in college.
Those powerful jobs that are open
and available are no longer open
to our girls if we don't
provide them education
in those formative years.
And so, people always
ask me like why?
Why have you seen this
dramatic decline of women?
Well, the first thing is culture.
Let's be honest.
We had a Barbie doll
that says, "I hate math."
"Let's go shopping instead."
We can walk into Forever 21
and buy a T-shirt that says
"I'm allergic to algebra."
When you turn on the
television and you look
at what a computer programmer
looks like, it's normally a dude
in a hoodie, sitting in
a basement somewhere.
He's drinking a red bull, and
he hasn't showered, right?
And little girls look at that image
and they say, not only do I not want
to be him, I don't even
want to be friends with him.
You cannot be what you cannot see.
And what our girls
see is this image.
And it has to change.
The second thing is and I don't
know how or when this started,
but how many girls in this room
have ever said, I hate math?
Or I hate science?
Raise your hand.
Now, how many of you ever said, I
hate to read or I hate to write.
All right, just there's
always like one.
Here's the thing.
It is culturally acceptable for
our girls and some of the moms
in this room to say I hate math.
I hate science.
I'm sure most of the moms in
this room have probably said
that before too, raise your hand.
And you might even feel comfortable
going into dinner party and be ugh,
I can't stand working with numbers.
Or maybe even at an interview.
Just, so you know, I'm not
that great with spreadsheets.
You would never walk
into a dinner party,
and certainly not an interview and
just say, I don't write that well.
It would not be socially acceptable.
So, we have a culture, and listen,
I love "Mean Girls,"
I watch it on repeat.
And you know the scene where she
crosses off the A and puts a D just
to get the affections of a
boy, we live in a culture
that celebrates this myth that
girls hate math and science.
And that they hate a skill that they
need to survive in the 21st century.
And it's got a change.
The second thing is, I've been
thinking about this a lot,
is I believe that we raise
our girls to be perfect,
and we raise our boys to be brave.
You know at a young age we
tell our girls to smile pretty,
play it safe, get all As.
And we teach our boys to crawl
to the top of the monkey bars
and just jump off headfirst.
I have a 2 1/2-year-old son,
which is very off-brand,
but I think about his
swimming class.
So, his swim class is like
half boys and half girls.
And when the girls are
learning how to swim,
all the parents are
like it's okay honey.
You don't have to get your face wet.
Don't be scared.
And with the boys,
they're like pushing them
into the deep end at six months.
The dads and the moms.
Because they're trying to
teach their sons how to be men.
How to be fearless.
How to be risk takers.
And as these young men grow up,
they raise their hands for jobs
that they know nothing about.
They're comfortable with
rejection and failure.
We live, in Silicon Valley they say
you can't even get funded unless
you've had two failed startups.
But for our girls, this coddling,
this protectionism has created
this generation of young women
that can handle critical feedback.
That gravitate towards things
that they're only good at.
That don't know how to be brave.
And it makes sense.
If from the time you are 16, if
you meet my son too, you will also;
I call him my little pig pen.
He's got a booger in his nose.
Yesterday's T-shirt.
His diaper should've been
changed six hours ago.
He's a mess.
But he's my mess.
And when I think about the girl,
the young girls in his life
and I watch their mothers
and their caretakers,
and I see them straighten
their dresses, fix their bows.
If something drops on their
shirt they run to go fix it.
Imagine if from 16 months
you are picked and plucked
and fixed how you feel by the
time you are 16 years old.
We have to change the way
we are raising our girls.
And I believe that coding
is a big part of that.
Because for those of you
who know how to code,
you know it is frustrating
process of imperfection.
That annoying semicolon
is in the wrong place,
you've got to do it over,
and over, and over again.
It teaches you how to fail.
It teaches you how to be imperfect.
So, in 2012, the failed
politician, the non-coder decided
to do something about it.
And I started an organization
called Girls Who Code.
And you know, when I
launched Girls Who Code,
I hand-picked my first 20 girls.
I borrowed a friend's
conference room.
I said to myself, Girls Who
Code, that's a great name.
I went on GoDaddy.com.
It was there.
I bought it for $1.99, and
I just tried something.
And we started with
20 girls in 2012,
less than five years later
we've taught 40,000 girls how
to code in all 50 states.
Don't, [applause] thank you.
[ Applause ]
And I want to put that into
perspective, remember I told you,
last year as a country we graduated
40,000 computer science graduates.
And Girls Who Code alone,
taught 40,000 girls.
Don't ever let anyone tell you
that a problem is not solvable.
Because it absolutely is.
And this is an example of that.
And what we do is two things.
We have free summer programs.
We basically embed classrooms
in technology companies.
We have 80 of those
programs in 11 cities,
1600 girls went through
that program.
And they're at Facebook, and
Twitter, and AT&T, Adobe, Pixar,
Disney, Sephora, Prudential,
Microsoft.
Every single major
technology company
in the country is building
a pipeline
of future technical workers on site.
The second thing we do is
we have afterschool clubs.
We have 1500 clubs in all 50 states.
And these clubs are at libraries,
schools; private schools,
public school, charter schools,
they're at homeless shelters.
NPR did a story of the first
ever club in a homeless shelter
where my girls would leave their
bedrooms at the top of the house,
and go downstairs to learn
how to computer program.
People always ask me, you
know, as you grow this program,
like how have you, how has
continued to make a difference.
And there's three major things.
One is capabilities.
We don't just tinker with code.
We teach girls to code.
And not only do we teach them how to
code, we teach them how to be brave.
How to be resilient.
How to be risk takers.
And it's that combination of
soft skills and hard skills.
The same things that we teach
in our book that will lead
to this generation
of powerful leaders.
The second thing we
teach are careers.
You know, my father was an engineer.
And I thought he fixed
choo-choo trains.
I had no idea what he did because
I never went to work with him.
And by building classrooms
in technology companies
and exposing our girls you know
to these amazing tech
leaders like Cheryl Samberg.
You know every year Cheryl Samberg
does a townhall with our girls.
And when the girls, when Cheryl
comes out, I remember at one
of our programs, she came
out wearing her cool leather
pants, and her cool shirt.
And the girls started
screaming like she was Beyoncé.
Because, for them, she is.
Role models are huge.
The third thing is community.
You know, our hashtag at Girls
Who Code is hashtag sisterhood.
For the girls in this room, and
for those of you who are still
in middle school, you know sometimes
we're not very nice to each other.
But at Girls Who Code,
we are sisters.
And we have girls from all walks
of life; black, Latino, trans, gay,
straight, Muslim, Christian, Jewish,
all walks of life that come together
and become friends and build
products and learn together.
It's this sense of
community that I believe
that these young women will build
the products of today and tomorrow.
And it's working, 93% of our
graduates are going on to major
or minor in computer science.
And the thing is, is 77% of them
walked into one of our programs,
maybe mom made them sign up.
Maybe dad did.
Maybe grandma.
And they went to Girls Who Code,
and they said, this is awesome.
Like I want to do this.
We can solve this problem.
It's fixable.
I am a feminist, with a capital,
capital F. I am [applause].
But I don't believe in gender parity
for the sake of gender parity.
I believe that there are so many
innovations that are sitting
on the sidelines because we're
not teaching girls to code.
And I think about my
students, I think about Cora
who was five years old when her
daddy got diagnosed with cancer.
And she decided at that moment
that she was to be a doctor,
because she wanted to
save her father's life.
And it wasn't until Girls Who
Code that she saw the connection
between medicine and coding.
Where she built an algorithm
to help detect whether a
cancer is benign or malignant.
I think about Jasmine, a single
mom, works at Burger King,
has four brothers and sisters.
Every day Jasmine would leave her
home in Oakland, take two buses
and two trains to Facebook to
learn how to computer program.
Until Girls Who Code she
had never met anybody
who was Latina that worked in tech.
And at Girls Who Code,
in our program you can
build whatever you want.
And Jasmine decided that she wanted
to build an app called Wacky Words.
Because too many kids in her
community, they wanted to march
up into the middle class too.
But they didn't have access to
fancy SAT tutors, and SAT classes.
So, she built an app to
help teach them SAT words.
She decided to not build
something for herself,
but to build something for others.
I think about Tricia
Probo [assumed spelling].
Tricia 16 years old,
Naperville, Illinois every day
of her life she was cyber bullied.
And on one day she was reading a
story about a girl in her community
that was 12 years old, that
climbed to the top of a building,
and jumped because she was
being bullied at school.
And Tricia said you know
how can, at 12 it be so bad.
So, she came home and she
built an app called rethink.
So, every time you're about to
set something that's not very nice
on text, and asks you are you
sure you want to send this?
Sixteen years old.
I would say if we want to find a
cure to cancer, teach girls to code.
We want to solve homelessness,
teach girls to code.
We want to do something about
climate change, teach girls to code.
Girls are change the ages.
They are our future leaders
and we must invest in them.
And we invested in them by
teaching them a skill set
that will allow them to
solve our world's biggest
and smallest problems.
And if you don't believe me, the
amazing things our girls have built,
go to our website and look
at our project gallery.
You will be amazed.
And you will agree that I do, that
our future, it's in good hands.
So, how can you help?
We've got to change culture.
I got a lot of parents in this
room, I know you're on social media.
You can get angry like me.
Let's do it.
This is a book that Mattel put out,
called "I Can be a
Computer Science Engineer."
So, the point of this
book was to inspire girls
to go into computer science.
I'm going to read it to you
real quick, for those of you
who can't see, that's Barbie
and that's her friend Skipper.
And Skipper says, "Your
robot puppy is so sweet.
Can I play your game?"
"I'm only creating
the design ideas."
Barbie says laughing.
"I need Steven and Brian's help
to turn it into a real game."
Boo is right.
In three sentences, Barbie
told millions of her fans
that you're not smart enough,
that you are not good enough,
that computers are for boys.
This stuff happens all the time.
And we got to shut it down.
We got to shut it down
because these images,
these words have a huge
effect on our girls.
Which leads me to why
I'm here today.
I grew up loving, loving
"Sweet Valley High."
The thing is, is I never saw
myself in those characters.
And so, I would go to audiences
like this all across the country
and invariably an amazing
teacher or a parent,
or a grandparent would come up to me
and she'd say, I'm with you Reshma.
I want to give my girl, my daughter,
my granddaughter, my niece,
my sister, I want to expose her
to this incredible
language what do I do?
Is there a book?
And I went online and
I went to bookstores,
and I realized there was no book.
And also, year, after year, after
year of growing our program,
we've had to turn girls away.
For our summer program, 7000
girls applied for 1600 spots.
I'm not running a competitive
coding program.
I just want to teach
all girls to code.
So, in partnership with
Penguin, we are coming out,
we came out last week with
two books and we have 13.
And these are books for all ages.
Our first two books "Learn
the Code, Change the World,"
and "The Friendship Code"
are for girls 8 to 12.
And "Learn to Code," you know,
it's about the pioneers
of computer science.
How many of you knew that the
world's first programmer was
a woman?
Great. And her name is Ada Lovelace.
And there's Ada and Grace
Hopper, and the ENIAC women;
Margaret Hamilton and
Catherine Johnson.
So many amazing, amazing
women that our girls
and boys need to hear about.
This book also kind of
tells you about the basics
of computational thinking.
Like algorithms, and
variables, and conditionals.
Tells you about some
of the incredible stories
that I shared with you.
And the book, it's not broccoli.
It's like M&Ms.
It's fun. And it's interesting.
And it's awesome.
And when you read it for the young
girls in this room, you're not going
to feel like we're
making you do something.
You're going to finish it
and be like, tell me more.
The next book that we have coming
out is "The Friendship Code."
It's kind of like our version of
"The Babysitting Club" meets coders.
And at the center of both of
these books are five girls.
Lelah, who wears a hijab.
Lucy who loves video games.
Sophia, who hasn't an Abuela.
Erin, who's the girl next door.
And Maia who loves fashion,
who's kind of like the cool kid.
These girls look like every single
one of the girls in this room.
Every single one of you are going
to identify with these characters
and see yourself in them.
This book is for each
and every one of you.
And I know you're going
to love them.
After you read these
books, or maybe before,
we want you to either join one
of our Girls Who Code clubs,
we're in all 50 states,
go on our website.
And if there's not a
club in your community,
I promise you, I will start one.
We want to get to 5000 clubs,
100,000 girls this year.
And we can do it.
Again, this problem is solvable.
I want to leave you with one
story for the dads in this room.
I was giving this talk
a couple years ago
and I got an email
from this guy Ken.
And Ken said, you know Reshma,
your story had an immediate
impact on my family.
I was at home and I
was telling my wife
about what you were talking about.
And that week, my grandparents;
my parents had sent my
son a Kano Computer Kit.
And my son was not
interested in it at all.
And as I was talking to
my wife about your story,
I realize that I had never asked
my daughter Sophie if she wanted
to play with the Kano Computer Kit.
And I looked at my daughter I
said, Sophie, honey you want
to play with the computer kit?
And she said daddy, I'd love to.
And he said Reshma, I
can't get her away from it.
Last message.
Let your girls get dirty.
Let them tinker.
Let them take things apart.
Put a drill in their hand
when they're 12 years old.
If the toilet's broken,
take them to go fix it.
Stop protecting and
coddling our girls.
Let's teach them how to be brave.
And it starts, as weird
as it's going to sound,
by teaching them how to code.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I think I have a couple
of minutes for questions.
If anybody has them.
>> Where can you get the books
and how do you sign
up for Girls Who Code?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: Amazing.
So, you can get the
books everywhere.
I'm doing a little book
signing after this.
And you can sign up for Girls
Who Code on our website.
Girlswhocode.com.
You got one more question?
No?
>> How many books do you have?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: How
many books do I have?
Right now, we have two
books that have come out.
"Girls Who Code" and
"The Friendship Code."
And then we have another 11 coming
out over the next couple of years.
>> Have you been to
the US Territories?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: Have I been to
the US Territories, I think so.
>> Excuse me?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: Yes, hi.
>> Pretty much.
Did you know that I actually
went to a coding club at my age,
even though everyone else was
pretty much older than me?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah.
Let's give her a big
round of applause.
I am so proud of you and
you keep doing that okay?
Did you like it?
>> Yeah.
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: You did?
>> Except all the other
ones are for older kids.
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: Well,
seems like you are going
to be a trailblazer then.
You need to tell all your friends
about it too, maybe
get them to join?
Okay.
>> What made you get the idea?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: What
made me get the idea?
All the amazing girls
that I've taught.
I have the best job in the world
because I get to work with girls.
And they inspire me.
And so, I wanted to
tell their stories,
and I wanted to share
all the awesome things
that I've learned from
teaching them.
Thank you.
>> I'm inspired in your programs, so
how do you get to the website again?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI:
It's girlswhocode.com.
Okay? And anybody can send me,
I probably shouldn't
do this but I will.
Anyone can send an email
at Reshma@girlswhocode.com
if you have any questions.
>> How many languages
of code is there?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: Well,
that's a great question.
How many languages of code is there?
A lot. But the thing is, is what
we teach is computational thinking
because a lot of languages change.
I'm sure there are
people in this room
that did basic right, way back when.
And now there's languages like
HTML and C+, so by the time you get
to be my age I don't even know
what the languages will be.
But that's what's awesome
because you can learn
computational thinking,
and then you can learn any language.
Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> So, I read your book and I
like it, how do I get started?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI:
Did you read the book?
And you liked it?
How old are you?
>> Ten.
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: Ten?
That's great.
So, I want you to go
on our website and see
if your school already
has a Girls Who Code club,
and if not we'll start one.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Did you write the
Girls Who Code books?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI:
So, great question.
So, the Girls Who Code, I'm the
author of the "Girls Who Code;
Learn to Code and Change the World."
And I had an amazing team.
I had a great illustrator.
I had a technical partner.
I had a writing partner.
And we have this amazing
partnership with Penguin.
So, on the fiction book.
This author Stacia wrote
"The Friendship Code."
And we worked together
with our team to make sure
that she could also tell,
kind of the computing concepts
that were really important.
So, what we do is get
amazing authors
that are writing board books, or
coloring books, or fiction series
and we partner with them.
>> I do scratch.com and I
do like HTML on Khan Academy
and I was wondering what
kind of language teach?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI: So, we teach,
that's awesome first of all.
For all the parents, scratch is
a great place to kind of start.
It's drag and drop.
So, it's probably the first thing
that, right, that you learned.
And I'm proud that
you're on Kahn Academy
because they have an amazing website
where you can actually watch videos
and have a coding platform
there at the same time.
You know the way that we teach
our Girls Who Code is the question
that we ask ourselves is
what do you want to build?
So, like if you want to
build an app, we often teach,
whether it's App Inventor or
Swift, if it's a website it's HTML.
And you know we teach C++ and Java.
But it's all about trying to first
decide what do you want to build
and then what's the
right language for that?
>> Okay.
>> Why does it start at?
Why do you have to
be in sixth grade?
>> RESHMA SAUJANI:
It's a great question.
So, you don't have
to be in sixth grade,
so our clubs first started
off being for high school.
And then we went a little
bit younger in middle school.
And then we wanted to serve girls
as young as we possibly can,
which is why we wrote these books.
I have a feeling that these books
are probably going to inspire a lot
of amazing young girls who
are going to probably push us
to start our clubs a little bit
younger, so more to come on that.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Awesome, well I hope you
come to our book signing.
And I think, I want to say one
more thing, all the proceeds
of the book go to Girls Who Code.
So, you're not just buying a book,
but you are helping
support a movement.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov